Sie zeichnen das auf. Alles gut.
Okay, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Rana Yüksel.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz Arsten Tätig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespiel führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor wir anfangen, würde gerne einfach eine Frage stellen.
Bevor wir anfangen, würde ich das Aufnahmegespiel hören.
Wie heißt sie da?
Ich heiße Sebastian Silberstein.
Ja, Sebastian, schreibt sich S-E-B-A-S-T-I-A-N.
Nn Sebastian Silberstein S-I-L-B-E-R-S-T-E-I-N Silberstein
Danke, Herr Silberstein. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 23 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. November 2001.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ich wiege zur Zeit 68 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
Wie lange sind Sie?
Ich fühle mich seit 3 Wochen ziemlich krank.
Ich bin müde, erschöpft.
Ich habe wenig Appetit.
Ich habe auch Fieber.
Meistens abends bis 38,5 kg.
Meistens abends?
Seit wann haben Sie das Fieber?
Seit 3 Wochen.
Wie lange sind Sie?
Ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Im Mund.
Ja.
Wie lange sind Sie?
Sie haben eine Schmerze.
Also, ich habe etwas..
Die Muskeln weh.
Die Muskel schmerzen.
dass mein Hals etwas geschwollen ist. Der ist irgendwie dicker geworden der Hals.
An der Seite besonders so habe ich das bemerkt. Aber das tut nicht weh.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, mein Bauch, gerade auf der linken Seite, im Oberbauch, auf der linken Seite, habe ich so ein Druckgefühl.
Auch keine Schmerzen, aber ein Druckgefühl. Das war vorher nicht.
Zihabun, Geshmoline, Herz. Beid, Zaytih oder Anzaytih?
Ja, auf beiden Seiten so, hier so an der Seite.
Okay.
Gleich Zaytihabun, Zeschul, Pechverden, Herzschmerzen.
Nein, eigentlich nicht so sehr. Schluck, Beschwerden, Halsschmerzen habe ich nicht so stark.
Hauptsächlich ist es mehr eine Schwellung.
Okay, Ziyabun, auf keinen Bauchschmerzen?
Nur ein Druckgefühl im Bauch, auf der linken Seite.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt habe ich noch nichts eingenommen.
Ich hatte da immer erst ab, aber jetzt merke ich, es geht nicht.
Und ich fühle mich zunehmend schwach.
Und deswegen komme ich jetzt zu Ihnen.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie einige Zettome?
Nein.
Mir ist mir nicht bekannt.
Hatten Sie früher einige Beschwerden wie heute?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für Ihre Beschwerden, Herr Silvastan?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Erklärung, was das sein kann, woran das liegen kann.
Ich mache sonst immer sehr viel Sport.
Aber seit drei Wochen mache ich das nicht mehr, weil ich bin zu müde.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen Herzrausen, Herzklopfen oder ein unregelmäßes Herzschulack aufgefallen?
Also mein Puls ist deutlich schneller als sonst.
Das habe ich bemerkt.
Ich bekomme auch schnell Luftnot.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel, ich wohne im zweiten Stock, die Wohnung.
Und wenn ich da hoch gehe, das hat mir sonst nie etwas ausgemacht.
Aber jetzt habe ich Luftnot.
Das muss ich auch sogar mit stehen bleiben.
Seit wann haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, auch seit drei Wochen.
Nur bei Bewegung.
In Ruhe haben Sie auch Atemnot?
Nein, in Ruhe nicht so sehr.
Aber weil ich mich bewege oder treppen steige, habe ich das.
Okay.
Leiden Sie auch unter Husten?
Ich habe zwei Asthma seit der Kindheit.
Aber nein, ich habe keine Husten.
Okay.
Habt ihr noch etwas andere Bescheid?
Nein.
Okay.
Habt ihr noch etwas andere Bescheid?
Zum Beispiel Hautveränderungen,
Schwellungen, Indenbeinen oder...
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber ich muss sehr stark nachts schwitzen.
Sie schwitzen, okay.
Seit drei Wochen?
Ja, auch so seit der Zeit.
Okay.
Gleichzeitig leiden Sie unter Schüttefrost?
Ja, habe ich auch mal.
Nicht immer, aber manchmal habe ich Schüttefrost.
Und eben wie gesagt das Viehbaum und Nachtschweiß.
Okay.
Sie haben schon Erwandt.
Sie haben Appetitlosigkeit.
Haben Sie in der nächsten Zeit auch Kutasur genommen?
Ich habe Gewicht abgenommen.
8 kg.
Das ist schon ein bisschen länger her.
Das ist vielleicht 6 Wochen, 8 Wochen?
Okay, 6, 8 Wochen.
Haben Sie besonders ein Diet gemacht?
Nein, keine Diät.
Okay.
Wie schlafen Sie, Herr Silberstein?
Ja, ich schlafe gut.
Aber seit ich mich so müde und schlafe fühle,
schlafe ich tagsüber manchmal.
Und dann habe ich nachts nicht so einen guten Schlaf.
Also zurzeit schlafe ich nicht gut.
Okay.
Ja, fühlen Sie sich kaxüber schläfrig?
Ja, müde, erschöpft.
Okay.
Wie sieht aus mit dem Sturgang, Herr Silberstein?
Nein, der Sturgang ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit etwas vermehrt Durchfall oder dünn.
Aber ja, Wasser lassen ist in Ordnung.
Wasser lassen in Ordnung?
Ja, Wasser lassen in Ordnung.
Wie oft haben Sie normalerweise Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise habe ich einmal bis zweimal am Tag Stuhlgang,
jetzt aber manchmal auch vier, fünf Mal.
Vier, fünf Mal.
Okay.
Wie sieht der Stuhlgang aus?
Ist Ihnen ein Übel oder müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein ist nicht der Fall.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen auch schwindelig?
Ja, wenn ich so schwach ist, manchmal wenn ich schnell aufstehe,
wenn ich aus dem Sitzen länger gesessen habe und ich stehe schnell auf,
dann ist mir auch etwas schwindelig.
Okay.
Haben Sie das Bewustein verloren?
Nein.
Und ob Sie ein Pulver, das ich einatmen muss,
Manchmal, wenn ich Sport mache, dann nehme ich auch manchmal Salbutamol.
Das ist das
auch seit der Kindheit ein chronisches Exem.
Besonders in der Kniekehle und am Ellenbogen, in der Ellenbeuge.
Im Winter ist es stärker, wenn es im Sommer Sonne scheint.
Im Winter ist es besser.
Im Winter besonders.
Es gibt noch andere, die für den Erkrankungen sind?
Nein, erst mal habe ich das Exem.
Siehst du, dass ich schon mal operiert habe?
Ja, ich wurde mit einem Alter von 10 Jahren an den Mandeln operiert.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich eine Behandlung, weil ich einen Meniscus-Riss hatte, am linken Knie.
Ich habe einen Meniscus-Riss gespielt, und da wurde eine Kniespiegelung gemacht.
Und dann wurde der Meniscus wieder repariert.
Seitdem habe ich eigentlich keine Beschwerden.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Herr Ezybistan, wie sieht es bei Ihnen?
Haben Sie allergin oder umfaltrechnigkeiten gegen bestimmte Lebensmittel?
Ich habe allergie getestet, wegen dem Asthma.
Ich habe allergin auf Hausstaub.
Das habe ich und auf manche Gräser und Polen.
Das ist bekannt.
Wie reagiert ihr auf das Asthma?
Herr Ezybistan, ich möchte zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten ein paar Fragen stellen.
Raufen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht, auch wegen dem Asthma nicht.
Das ist sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, eine oder zwei Flaschen Bier pro Woche.
Nehmen Sie diese nächste Frage, nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routinmäßige Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drohke?
Nein.
Nein?
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihrer Familienanamnese.
Sie kommen in Ihrer Familie von der Chronischen Erkrankung.
Ja, der Vater hatte früher zwölf Finger-Darm-Geschwüre.
Der Vater ist 52 Jahre alt, er lebt noch.
Er hat seit ungefähr fünf Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Er muss auch Medikamente nehmen.
Mein Vater hatte vor zwei Jahren, nach einer Corona-Infektion, eine Herzmuskellenzündung.
Das ist aber ganz gut ausgeheilt.
Er ist wieder ganz gut belastbar.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Er ist 52 Jahre alt.
Der Vater ist 52 Jahre alt.
Er ist der Mutter gesund?
Die Mutter ist 51 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter hat auch Asthma.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Die ist 24 Jahre alt.
Die ist gesund.
Sie sind sehr jung, aber trotzdem sind Sie verheiratet oder haben Sie einen Partnerin?
Ja, Partnerin, aber ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Okay.
Sie sind mit Ihrer Partnerin?
Ja.
Was ist das für Sie?
Sie sind Studentin oder?
Ja, ich studiere Jura.
Ich studiere Jura.
Wie ist die Stress?
Das jubelste Studium ist manchmal sehr anstrengend.
Viele Prüfe und viele Klausuren.
Aber ich konnte das in den letzten drei Wochen nicht alles machen.
Ich war so erstopft.
Ich verstehe sie.
Sie waren in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, vor drei Monaten habe ich eine Reise gemacht mit meiner Partnerin.
Da war ich in Thailand, in Vietnam.
Vier Wochen lang?
Vier Wochen lang.
Sie sind geblieben?
Ja.
Sind Sie vollständig geblieben?
Ja, besonders vor der Reise nach Thailand.
Vietnam war ich bei einem Tropenmediziner.
Er hat spezielle Impfungen gemacht.
Ich habe auch Tabletten gegen Malaria genommen.
Ich musste für zwei Tage aussetzen.
Ich hatte eine Magendahminfektion.
Ich musste zwei Tage die Tabletten pausieren.
Sind die Schmerzen nach der Reise aufgetreten?
Ja, ich war vor drei Monaten da.
Die Schmerzen oder Beschwerden sind jetzt seit drei Wochen.
Ich bin fast fertig.
Siebestein, möchte Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, die ich wissen sollte?
Ja, das kann nicht sein.
Das macht mich schon Sorgen.
Ich habe noch nie so etwas gemacht.
Sie haben momentan eine gute Reise gemacht.
Aber ich habe mich noch nicht geblieben.
Ich habe noch nicht geblieben.
Das ist eine gute Reise.
Ich habe mich noch nicht geblieben.
Okay.
Okay, das können wir so machen. Sehr gut.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Nicht ganz so lange wie in der Prüfung, da sind das ja 20 Minuten.
Übersetzen Sie die Patientensprache möglichst in die medizinischen Begriffe.
Und Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die zugehört und zugeschaut haben,
haben vielleicht noch Fragen oder Ergänzungen.
Man möchte ich Sie bitten, dass Sie die auch bitte jetzt stellen.
Irgendwelche Lymphknoten bemerkt?
Lymphknoten.
Oder Schwellungen.
Also, mein Hals ist dicker geworden, so an der Seite.
Mein Hals ist dicker, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Es kann sein, dass das Lymphknoten sind.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Sind Sie schmerzhaft?
Nein, sind eigentlich nicht schmerzhaft.
Können Sie die Schwellung einfach bewegen?
Das habe ich so noch gar nicht richtig ausprobiert.
Ich habe auch noch dieses Druckgefühl im Bauch links.
Und haben Sie das Gefühl, dass die Schwellungen mit der Seite größer geworden sind?
Ja, das kann sein.
Die Schwellungen waren auch noch nicht sofort von Anfang an da.
Die sind in den letzten zehn Tagen gekommen.
Haben Sie Yukreis auch dazu?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe manchmal Yukreis an der Stelle, wo ich Exem habe.
Ich habe das in der Kniekehle und am Ellenbogen.
In der Ellenbäuge.
Da juckt die Haut häufiger, aber sonst habe ich keinen anderen Yukreis.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie gelb sucht?
Gelb sucht?
Ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ja, gerne.
Ich bin jetzt der Oberarzt.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Und für den ganzen Tag mit Ihnen, die diesen Fall, die ich hier bin.
Es geht um Sebastian Zilbösch.
Er ist 23 Jahre alt, 880 kg schwer,
1,8 Meter groß.
Er hat 7 Stange.
Er stammelt sich heute bei uns wegen 3 Wochen.
Er ist 5,5 Meter schwer.
Er hat 4,5 Grad Begleitung.
Er ist 30,5 Grad.
Er ist auch in einer Petansform.
Er ist auf dem
dass ihr als Geschevolen sind, wahrscheinlich,
der Knoten, bei Zartik.
Ihr könnt eventuell sagen, der Patient berichtet über zervikale Schwellungen
oder über Schwellungen zervikal.
Ich würde noch gar nicht jetzt sagen, vermutlich sind es Lymphknoten,
der Patient berichtet das.
Der Patient berichtet noch über, ich nenne das deutsche Wort,
über Muskelschmerzen.
Ja, myalgien auch.
Okay, myalgien auf alle Fälle.
Es bestehen myalgien, es besteht die Artiksymptomatik
und febrile Temperaturen 38,5.
Wissen Sie, wo der Patient gemessen hat?
Im Mund oral können wir sagen, oral gemessen.
Ja, erwandte auf Druckgefühl im Bauch.
Wahrscheinlich, ja, es könnte Splenomegalis sein.
Okay, der Patient berichtet über ein unklares Druckgefühl
im linken Oberbauch.
Ich würde das Wort Splenomegalis vielleicht noch gar nicht benennen.
Ist Ihre Idee, die ja nicht recht ist?
Die Idee, ich würde jetzt im Augenblick
noch wenig Vermutungen erst mal machen.
Ich würde nur sagen, der Patient berichtet
über ein Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch.
Ja, okay.
Druckgefühl im linken Oberbauch.
Diese Beschwarten sind erst mal aufgetreten.
Er klagte über auf Belastungsdisziplinen.
Beim Treppensteigen, normalerweise,
er macht immer Sport.
Aufgrund ihrer aktuellen Beschwarten,
zurzeit konnte er nicht, ja, keinen Sport treiben.
Okay.
Auf dem Aufschritt der Klagte über auf Vertigo.
Auf der Klagte über auf Vertigo.
Vier bis fünf Mal momentan.
Aber kein Blut im Stur.
Okay, gut.
Indirektative Anamnese.
Weil gewicht für 18 Kilogramm in sechs bis acht Wochen
auffählig, auch in Sonne, in Svezon, in Indianacht.
Okay.
An vor Erkrankungen, leider der Patient,
Asthma Brunhiale, seit Kindheit.
Ja.
Und ja, Coronisches Exam, vielleicht, Dermatitis.
Inspezon der Alm.
Am Ellenbogen und Poplitalperi.
Ja, Poplital, die Kielkele.
Und am Ellenbogen mehr ist es die Innenseite.
Da sagen wir eventuell Kubital.
Kubital.
Im inneren Bereich der Ellenbogen.
Das kann ein Exem, ein Neurodermitis oder so etwas sein.
Oft in Verbindung mit Asthma.
Ja.
Okay.
Und Ernehme zweimal täglich, wir nie ein.
Bei Bedarf, insbesondere vor Darm-Sport,
Nehme, Eyal, Zarbitomol, Supri-Ein.
Ja.
Im Altefum Sinjar, Ersorgte, Tonzelektomie.
Für Svajjarin,
Zaj, Baydia, Baym-Patientin,
Meniskus, Ruphtur,
Festgestart, deswegen mit Atroskopie,
Behandlung bekommen der Patient.
Okay, ja.
Ja, habe Hausstab-Alargi.
Mhm.
Ja, auch Gräser, Polen.
Und Erreagiere darauf mit Asthma-Symptomatik.
Okay.
Indianoxinonemnese, Zaj, der Patient, nicht raufherr.
Er trinke Eins- bis Wife-Leischer, Bia-Provohe.
Drogenkonsumur, der verneut.
Indefamilien-Alamnese,
Kaptee-Fassient an, der Fatah,
Al-Udkustoduni, Leide.
Ja.
Und ja, der Zvajund,
Fürse-Jerige Fatah, Leide auf,
Arterieli, Für-Partnerin, Zajt, Fürfjahrin.
Und fürse-Jerren,
Hat der Fatah Corona-Infect, Covid-Noise,
Danach hat der Fatah an Myocarditis gelitten.
Ja, okay.
Aber zur Seite,
Er hat sich gut erfolgt.
Okay.
Ja.
Die, die 41-Jährige Mutter,
Leiden Asthma-Bronchalevi, der Patient,
Ja.
Auf Schwester ist gesund,
Für um 20 Jahre alt.
Der Patient sei ledig,
Aber wohne mit einer Partnerin,
Seiner Partnerin.
Und er schütte die Erhörige
Im Berach von Jura.
Ja, er studiert Jura, ja.
Er studiert Jura.
Seit er habe Stress.
Und ja, Reise-Anamnese war aufwählig
Vor drei Monaten,
Der Patient in Thailand und Vietnam
gewesen und dort für Wohne
Ja, ist geblieben.
Mhm.
Vor der Reise,
habe der Patient Malere Profilepsi,
Aber er hat nicht gut vertragen,
Deswegen ein bis zwei Tage absetzen.
Okay.
Also, der Patient, sagen Sie vielleicht,
Der Patient war vor der Reise,
ist vor der Reise tropenmedizinisch betreut worden,
Also mit Impfungen, mit notwendigen Impfungen.
Und er hat während des Aufenthaltes
eine Malaria-Prophylaxe betrieben.
Mhm.
Diese Malaria-Prophylaxe wurde für zwei Tage pausiert.
Pausiert?
Wohl wegen einer Gastroenteritis.
Der Patient hatte wohl einen Magendamenfekt.
Mhm.
Und konnte er nichts zu sich nehmen.
Da hatte er die Tabletten nicht genommen für zwei Tage.
Ja.
Okay.
Und sie sei auf posten geheim,
oder der Patient erwandt.
Ja, die Anamnestischen,
Angabun, Doitun, Amähestun,
ja, Infektionsmononidlose hin.
Infektionsmononidlose, ja, okay.
Die Ferroasiakostischkommung,
ja, Lampform,
auf Hepatitis,
oder Malaria,
Malaria in Betracht.
Ja, das reicht, denke ich.
Also, wichtig ist, dass sie eine Verdachtstiagnose nennen,
die Verdachtstiagnose, Infektionse, Mononokliose.
Am gut passend, das Alter des Patienten,
ist noch dafür passend, das Fieber.
Er hat wenig Halsschmerzen direkt.
Er hat nur diese zernikale Schwellung bemerkt.
Mhm.
Es gibt es bei der Mononokliose natürlich auch.
Es gibt auch dieses Druckgefühl im Oberbauch.
Wie würden Sie das interpretieren?
Das ist die blöde Geheimnis.
Als Splenomegalie?
Oder als, was kann es sein?
Dieses Druckgefühl im Oberbauch.
Der Patient hat so ein Obergefühl im linken Oberbauch.
Kann eventuell eine Splenomegalie sein, ja?
Mhm.
Das kann bei der Mononokliose sein.
Es kann aber auch bei der zweiten Verdachtstiagnose
eines Lymphomes sein.
Ich weiß, der Patient hat eine doch auffällige Gewichtsabnahme.
Ja, ist richtig.
Von 8 Kilogramm.
Da und eine B-Symptomatik würde ich sagen,
das würde mich eher in die Richtung eines Lymphomes
wahrscheinlich führen.
Infektionse, Mononokliose.
Und natürlich kann es auch eine Malaria sein.
Mhm.
Das kann sein.
Das sind aber Dinge, die Sie relativ schnell und gut abklären können.
Die Malaria im Labor.
Die anderen Dinge, die infektionse, Mononokliose natürlich auch.
Aber die schwerwiegendere Diagnose wäre wahrscheinlich das Lymphom.
Mhm.
Für den Patienten.
Vielen Dank.
Ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht, sehr strukturiert.
Sie haben eigentlich nichts Wesentliches vergessen.
Und ich habe Sie auch gut verstanden.
Sie müssen manchmal aufpassen.
Sie sagen eher der Patient, aber dann sagen Sie häufiger auch,
Sie hat Gewicht abgenommen.
Also versuchen Sie da wirklich dann auch bei Maskulinum zu bleiben.
Aber das ist nicht so ganz entscheidend.
Entscheidend finde ich es wichtig, die Struktur der Anamnese,
die Verständlichkeit, die auch die Fachbegriffe
konnten Sie sehr gut übersetzen.
Das fand ich alles gut.
Und ja, und wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Und es war 6.00 Uhr im Juli.
Juli?
Ja, also in gut 4 Wochen.
Ja, 4 Wochen.
Gut, und wo machen Sie die?
In Freiburg, als der Kamer.
Freiburg, ja.
Freiburg.
Wo wohnen Sie in Freiburg oder im Umfeld?
In den Neha von Freiburg.
Es dauert eine Stunde lang.
Wo nach Süden, nach Basel?
Oder in den Schwarzwald?
Ja, Basel auf Indien-Neha, aber in der Grenze.
Lörrach.
Dann befindet sich Wer.
Wer ist der Kanes dort?
Wer, okay.
Ich habe in Freiburg studiert.
Oh, super.
Und war da auch 13 Jahre in Freiburg.
Freiburg fahre ich immer wieder gerne hin.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für die Vorbereitung.
Und Sie werden diese Prüfung gut machen.
Grüßen Sie mir, Südbaden.
Ich sage mal Tschüss.
Nächste Woche um 18 Uhr können wir gerne wieder machen.
Gerne, vielen Dank.
Ich sage erst mal noch einen schönen Abend.
Tschüss.